[Music]
did you know that disney is reportedly
planning on making a new pirates of the
caribbean movie starring margot robbie
so does that mean johnny depp fresh off
his trial win against ex-wife amber
heard will make a cameo as captain jack
sparrow keep watching to find out the
defamation lawsuit johnny depp brought
against ex-wife amber heard ended with a
fairfax county virginia jury ruling in
depth's favor on all three charges depp
in turn was found to have defamed heard
on one of the three claims she brought
against her ex-husband in a countersuit
with 15 million dollars awarded in
damages to depp and two million dollars
awarded to heard at the end of the trial
although the actual financial numbers
are a bit trickier throughout the trial
and its aftermath public opinion swayed
significantly toward depp's side even
despite heard's own testimonies
presented evidence and the fact that a
british court ruled in 2020 that depp
had physically abused heard on a number
of occasions heard plans to appeal the
lawsuit's verdict so the public may not
be rid of the much publicized case yet
for now speculation runs rampant about
the future of both depps and herd's
acting careers after the trial but one
anonymous former disney executive made a
bold prediction for depp and the future
of the pirates of the caribbean film
series he helped make a massive pit you
are without doubt the worst pirate i've
ever heard of
but you have heard of me people recently
reported that an anonymous former disney
executive thinks the company could
conceivably ask johnny depp to return to
the pirates of the caribbean franchise
in the wake of his defamation trial
against amber heard the former executive
whom people did not name said that there
is too much box office potential for a
fan favorite character like jack sparrow
not to return to a blockbuster franchise
the former executive told people with
producer jerry bruckheimer riding high
on the massive success of tom cruise and
top gun maverick there is huge appetite
for bringing back bankable hollywood
stars in massively popular franchises
bringing depp back as jack sparrow
surely would bring significant attention
back to the pirates franchise which has
not released a film since the fifth
installment dead men tell no tales in
2017. according to box office mojo the
movies are the 16th highest grossing
film franchise ever in the us and canada
having collectively made over 1.45
billion dollars bruckheimer recently
told the times that two scripts for
future pirates movies are being written
one as a spin-off starring margot robbie
and another without robbie's involvement
bruckheimer also said that depp was not
expected to return for now but noted
that the future has not been decided yet
reports of the future pirates of the
caribbean movie featuring margot robbie
date back to 2020 when the hollywood
reporter wrote that a robbie starring
film would serve as a completely
original story using the franchise's
title even then thr reported that the
project would be separate from the next
entry in the main series a second
anonymous hollywood source who has
worked on past pirates movies told
people that they would expect jerry
bruckheimer and disney to make robbie's
character jack sparrow's daughter and
include johnny depp in a cameo
appearance to show to test audiences
there is one snag to those theories
although depp claimed that he had wanted
to keep playing jack sparrow through the
end of the pirates franchise he
testified during the defamation trial
that nothing would convince him to work
with disney on future projects nothing
on this earth would get you to go back
and work with disney on a pirates of the
caribbean film that is true mr
rottenborn while that testimony does not
legally prevent depp from choosing to
return to the franchise it is slightly
unclear whether disney or other major
hollywood studios will show interest in
bringing depp on the actor's former
agent tracy jacobs testified that it
grew harder to work with depp in the
late 2000s and 2010s since he had gained
a reputation for consistently showing up
late to the set of almost every movie he
made a third anonymous source told
people that they don't quite believe
depp would turn down a major paycheck
from disney to return as jack sparrow
given the well-publicized financial
troubles that dogged up in the 2010s
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]